going back to putting a price on her
arms day I think a lot of artists
filmmakers whatever have this idea that
money is sort of the root of all evil
and that there's a humility in being
poor or not asking for a lot of money
the other me get over that or is that
something that takes a lot of
soul-searching osorno there's no one
path for that I think that's a lot of
sometimes thats talked a lot of people
from monetizing there too they think
that it's humble that is good to be sort
of modest yeah you know that's that's so
true so many of us have such this big
problem with money right that we're
afraid to accept it and we're afraid to
ask for it I don't know I'm not a
therapist I can't I can't dive down into
what that's about I think that a lot of
it does come from people's upbringing
and what was put on people when they
were kids and what their parents gave
them but look money is neither evil nor
good money is money money is a means to
an end money isn't means to pay the ramp
and do your car payments and have dinner
tonight and it's just really awful and
wrong that people who are values driven
and creatively driven don't feel that
they have enough self-worth to ask for
the money for their work I just I would
love to change that if there's one thing
that I could change with a wave of my
hand if I had the magic power that's
what I would change I would totally
invert the way people are paid and the
way people ask for money in my ideal
society creative people in teachers
would be the highest-paid people and
then everybody else would be somewhere
below
you